polish architect Jakob Chesney is on his
way to one of his projects four years
ago he discovered this gap between two
buildings in Warsaw
although it's too narrow for a driveway
he thought there was just enough room
for a house the house is 1 meter 22
across at its widest point making the
finished product quite possibly the
world's thinnest home this was the
biggest challenge in my life because I
have never done something as narrow at
the entrance to the house the building
is just 72 centimeters wide but inside
it accommodates all the amenities of
modern day living Israeli writer Edgar
cadet is the official resident of the 14
and a half square metre space the house
is located in the Volga district once
Warsaw's Jewish ghetto Kenneth's mother
was smuggled out of the ghetto as a
child and escaped death the author has
already spent a few nights in the house
that carries his family's name well you
know before I came here with very much
afraid that he it would be Christopher
beak you know it will be dark I feel
like a sardine in eighteen but they
actually feel very comfortable later I
think it's designed in such a way you
know there is a lot of lighting under
Polish law the house is too small to be
considered a residence so it's
classified as an art installation well
the first time I've heard about this
idea was it when kuba called me and try
to explain to me over the phone they do
that he had for this very narrow house
important explaining it all in English
with a very heavy polish accent and it
always sounded like a prank or a joke I
thought it was one of my friends trying
to fool me Jakob Chesney belongs to a
collective called central ax that has a
reputation for experimental architecture
designing ketut house didn't take the 36
year old much time what did was the red
tape addressing ownership issues
building regulations and financing
Chesney needed to drum up some 70,000
euros to realize the project
the steel frame was put together at a
parking lot on the outskirts of Warsaw
we have received one-third of the money
we were applying for from the city of
Warsaw and which meant that we had to
start building without having the whole
Sun so we had to spend this 1/3 on what
was to steal construction but then the
rest of money we had to find it
somewhere private donors helped a Polish
Art Foundation owns the house wedging
the steel frame into the gap was a
challenge carrot house is one Chesnee
prays and calls from potential customers
around the world another possibility for
a small house is actually here filling
building gaps has become Chesney's new
mission
Ketut house he says is just the
beginning
net kakarrot lives mostly in tel-aviv
when he's not in Warsaw carat house is
used by artists I couldn't imagine
myself living here eh
but they could imagine it as their
working studio like I could imagine
myself coming here every day for a few
hours or writing and thinking for carat
the narrow house is inspirational he
says it's architect has given tangible
shape to a crazy idea